Thermals — let's start with thermals.
We have the sun, as we've discussed,
the engine of the weather — the sun shines on the Earth's surface
and warms the ground.
Accordingly, you get a slightly warmer air layer at the ground.
That's really important for understanding thermals,
when you're flying
or when you have to search for thermals,
you always have to ask yourself:
which air mass, or which ground, is going to heat up more?
Different surfaces warm up differently.
It's always about a temperature difference.
It's not as if you can never fly thermals in winter.
If the meadows are snow-free, for example,
they warm up more than snow-covered fields.
Accordingly, thermals can be found over the woods.
So the temperature difference is always really important.
This also has to do with the albedo effect —
for example, which surface warms up more strongly than another.
A dry ploughed field,
freshly harrowed, warms up more than a green meadow,
which is even better than a wet one.
So you always have to ask: which surface warms up more?
And there are basic rules for this:
if you have a reflective surface, like snow,
it barely warms up at all.
Whereas a black surface, a dark surface,
naturally warms up a lot more,
because it absorbs the sun's rays.
What's also really important
for warming is the angle of incidence.
Ideally the sun hits the surface at a right angle.
Then the surface gets heated much more strongly
than a tilted surface,
where the sun's rays only hit at a shallow angle.
Think for example of the polar regions versus the tropics.
That's also purely down to the angle of incidence of the sun.
Exactly.
Accordingly,
a warm layer of air forms at the ground,
which starts to bubble a bit.
This warm air layer, once the temperature difference is big enough
and it gets released by a small trigger,
it detaches and starts rising.
You can picture it
like a lava lamp — an air mass that stays together,
an air mass with uniform properties.
It's warmer than the surrounding air,
and it rises away.
So we have two air masses with different properties —
the one that matters has a certain temperature,
which we'll touch on briefly later.
And that warmer layer that rises, the bubble,
that's what forms the thermal.
We can also picture a hot-air balloon —
it also rises because it has warmer air inside,
which is less dense.
And so the hot-air balloon rises.
It's the same with a thermal, with this thermal bubble
rising up.
Now, we have a certain air pressure
in our atmosphere,
and lower down the air pressure is higher than in the upper layers.
Let's come back to air pressure.
Now we can tie things together here.
So when a balloon like this rises —
think of those buoyancy bags from diving,
or a weather balloon, you can see it really clearly.
When it's down low,
it has a very small volume of gas inside.
When it rises and the air pressure drops,
the gas can expand more and more.
Accordingly, the volume of the rising air parcel increases.
And from that we can get to the cooling.
When the balloon rises,
there's a decompression,
the pressure on the rising air parcel drops.
It expands, the pressure drops.
And when in an air mass, in a gas,
the overall pressure drops,
the temperature drops too.
We see this really clearly, for example,
with compressed-air canisters —
when you blow air out, it's ice-cold.
That's purely because the compressed air from the compressor
expands very quickly and cools down.
So an air mass that expands cools down.
And the opposite holds too:
if an air mass is compressed, it warms up.
You see this in practice, for example, when you pump up a tyre —
when you inflate a high-pressure tyre,
it gets quite warm.
That's because you've compressed a lot of air into it.
Keep that image in mind — it's really important for various
meteorological phenomena, including thermals.
If you put numbers on it, you can imagine
an air parcel leaving the ground at 20 degrees,
the sun goes up,
and the temperature keeps dropping with altitude.
Exactly — it has to do with the compression
and with rising air masses.
Now, you have to picture this simply:
in the atmosphere we have a certain temperature gradient.
Ideally it gets colder with altitude.
That's just how the air mass behaves — at night, for example.
At night the air mass sits there,
and at the ground it's noticeably warmer than up high on Mount Everest.
It's much colder up there than down here at sea level,
say at the seaside.
And that's the temperature gradient —
there's a profile, a gradient,
because the temperature gradient varies with these inversions
(unclear)
and other processes.
The thermal cap is reached at the point
where the air mass has reached minus 2 degrees.
And the ambient air,
wherever you are on the day,
is at some equilibrium point — it's exactly the same
as the parcel.
Accordingly, the hot-air balloon
no longer has a heat advantage.
And it won't rise any further.
The thermal stops at an equilibrium point.
Exactly.
It has to do with the atmospheric state curve,
with the state of the atmosphere.
The profile actually just describes the atmosphere,
the layering of the air masses as they sit.
The cooling
that takes place here
is also described as an adiabatic process,
or adiabatic cooling.
And there are two kinds.
We'll get to those in a moment with the glider pilot,
and you can
picture how the air mass behaves from its starting state.
Just shown another way,
to imagine
that we're dealing with two different air masses.
That's really important.
There's very little mixing between them.
And especially for the theory exam, what you learn,
that's what's relevant.
There's an advanced meteo course
where you'll learn a lot more about thermal theory.
There are other effects there
that are relevant,
but they go too far for the basic theory course.
Exactly.
So now we have the temperature drop
that the air parcel goes through.
And then a second factor comes in
that's really important for the pilot,
and that's humidity.
In an air parcel —
in this room here too —
we have a mixture including water vapour.
We don't just have oxygen and nitrogen,
but a mixture that includes water vapour.
So in this air parcel there's a certain humidity.
(unclear)
Depending on what kind of air mass it is,
you can picture it
with little blue dots representing water vapour
in there.
And as the air parcel rises
and cools off,
at some point the water vapour
in the air parcel reaches
(unclear)
the change point where the air mass can no longer hold the humidity.
And then
the gaseous water vapour
starts changing into liquid.
Liquid is relative — we usually see it as clouds.
Every bit of fog and every cloud
is essentially nothing other than
water in the air.
Tiny, microscopic water droplets.
You have to say — it's not like rain,
but really, really tiny droplets
that look to us, to the naked eye,
more like gas,
but they're actually water droplets in the air.
And we talk about the condensation level here —
the water vapour simply condenses out.
It comes out of the gas.
Another term you'll come across
is relative humidity,
expressed as a percentage.
At 100% you've reached the point
where the air mass can no longer hold any more moisture.
Exactly.
When the condensation process kicks in,
when the water vapour turns into water,
when it really becomes tiny water droplets,
then physically there's also
a phenomenon —
when it changes from gas to liquid,
heat is released.
A little bit of heat is released.
And likewise when it goes from liquid
to solid,
more heat is released —
a bit of energy is released in the process.
The other way around it's reversed:
when you change states,
from solid to liquid or from liquid to gas,
then heat is consumed.
An important point about the condensation process
is the rough rule of thumb
we can look at here.
And it's important
to understand roughly what's happening.
When the air mass rises,
it cools down.
So as long as,
following the dry adiabat,
it rises
without
any condensation process
happening,
it's quite simple:
it's just 1 degree
per 100 metres.
So as it rises,
it cools by 1 degree
per 100 metres.
Within this thermal bubble.
It's really simple —
an easy number to remember.
Easy to remember.
With the moist adiabat,
the adiabat,
the number is
lower,
(unclear)
because a warm air mass can hold more moisture than a cold one.
A warm air mass holds more moisture,
starts to condense later than a colder air mass, like polar air.
Accordingly the value is a bit higher.
But for us it's enough to know that it's less than one degree.
That's a quick rule of thumb for moist adiabatic cooling.
We can keep the number in mind, and now let's look at
what this means in practice.
Let's take an air mass that's rising.
In this case, dry adiabatic cooling, one degree
per 100 metres.
At a certain point the rising air mass reaches
the condensation level, and the condensation process begins.
From that point the air mass only cools
in this case by 0.65 degrees per 100 metres.
That's the moist adiabatic process.
It continues until at some point
the air parcel has the same temperature as the surrounding air —
those are the two adiabatic cooling processes,
and that's exactly how it works.
Then we have a picture from real flying.
You see the landscape.
Something triggers up front, where the air mass is best released.
Or where the ground heats up the most.
That's perpendicular solar radiation.
There are a few spots that heat up a bit more
than the ground in general.
In this case white surfaces, for instance,
heat up a bit more than the forest.
And here in this scenario my thermal bubble starts up here,
rises and rises and rises.
And at some point in this case it forms
a beautiful cumulus cloud
that marks the thermal bubble.
If you have wind on top of that,
then it's the same as with a balloon rising —
it gets drifted by the wind.
So it's a bit of a puzzle game,
when you get into cross-country flying — flights are always
a bit of piecing things together,
asking where the thermal releases
and where the nice cloud forms.
Another important point —
the thermal, the rising thermal air mass,
doesn't always have to form a cumulus cloud.
It can also be that the temperature advantage
of the thermal bubble, like the balloon, is exhausted —
that things equalise
before the condensation process happens.
Then you have exactly the same thing happening,
the same thermal,
but it stops rising
before condensation occurs.
Accordingly we talk about blue thermals.
That's the term — a blue thermal
is really nothing other than a thermal
that never condensed.
Exactly.
Another term in thermal theory
you'll come across is the lee —
around the lee, sheltered from the wind,
the wind-sheltered side of the mountain.
The side facing away from the wind on the mountains.
We have sun-exposed slopes,
and the surfaces that are at the right angle to the sun
heat up more than the other side.
Accordingly the thermal releases best there.
So we talk about lee thermals,
thermals that typically come up
on the wind-sheltered side.
This of course happens mostly
when you have northerly wind in the Alps for example,
because in the Alps the south-facing sides of the mountains
are always best,
so the side benefits most
when you have a northerly wind or Bise,
the wind comes from the north.
Accordingly the lee thermal is very pronounced.
Lee thermals usually have the characteristic
of being more turbulent.
We've already seen lee or mechanical turbulence.
We'll keep coming back to it.
We have mechanical turbulence
that of course breaks the thermal up.
It's a leeside rotor
that, depending on wind strength, makes the thermal more turbulent.
But mostly the lee thermal is also stronger.
Because the air parcel sheltered in the lee, in the wind-protected area,
has more time to heat up,
it heats up,
absorbs much more heat,
than a windward thermal, for example,
where, if the wind blows the other way,
the air parcel keeps getting blown away.
And the air mass in the wind
doesn't heat up as long as in the lee thermal.
This is something that's more advanced,
but it's good to know — what's important
is just to know that there's such a thing as a lee thermal.
Now let's go back to the temperature curve
we started with — let's go through it again.
It's really important.
There are two air masses.
We're talking about the thermal, the air mass
that rises.
And we're talking about the air mass
that just sits there at night,
which represents the state of the entire air mass
over Switzerland at that moment.
And from this point on
we're really only talking about the air mass,
not the thermal.
There are different scenarios.
Ideally,
or normally,
the warm air mass —
it gets colder with altitude.
So it gets colder the higher you go.
Then we talk about an unstable
layering of the air.
You can picture this:
as the air balloon rises,
it can hold its temperature advantage for a long time,
because the surroundings get colder,
rather than the other way round.
The other case is
a so-called inversion.
These come with special weather situations,
for example with high-pressure influence —
you get inversions,
where the opposite is true,
where it's cold in the valley
and up at the mountain summit
it's very warm.
You know this in winter perhaps,
maybe,
it's cold,
and up at the mountain summit,
skiing, you have the most beautiful weather,
you're almost in a T-shirt.
That's a so-called inversion.
And now picture this:
if a thermal rises through into
an inversion,
where suddenly it gets warmer with altitude,
then we no longer have a temperature advantage.
Then there's a stop,
the air masses simply can't keep rising.
Accordingly we talk about a very stable layering.
That's a stable layering.
So very little thermal activity is to be expected,
very calm air masses,
and you get really milky conditions.
Calm conditions,
beautiful for hike-and-fly and so on,
but not so great for thermal flying.
And then in between you have
a so-called isothermal layer.
That's the one
where the temperature with altitude
stays exactly the same.
So if you have 60 degrees in the valley
and 60 degrees at the summit,
then that's the so-called isothermal,
an unchanging air layer.
Exactly.
The normal state,
though, in the atmosphere,
is definitely
cooling with altitude,
getting colder and colder.
Now there are some exam questions
on these inversions
or unstable stratifications
where you see a temperature gradient written out.
The text might say at 500 m it's 50 degrees,
at 800 m it's 40 degrees —
the gradient is listed like that.
And then you're asked:
OK, where do we have an inversion?
Then you think it through,
you work through the data,
you look at 500 m, and remember.
And remember — an inversion
is the reverse of the air layering.
That means it gets warmer with altitude.
Then you just have to spot the numbers.
In this example,
it would be 50 degrees and at 800 m it's 60 degrees.
That would be an inversion.
The same with a high-altitude inversion —
the same thing happens,
just at higher altitude.
Or an isothermal,
at both altitudes
the same — unchanging air layer.
Exactly.
There's a little exam-rule example.
Then we can move on to the next chapter,
what's important,
we'll do the chapter on
cloud naming,
cloud shapes,
how clouds form and what we need to know.
With clouds it's the case
that we're working with a system
of Latin names,
and it's very complicated
to remember and to memorise.
And altogether it's a real jungle.
So let's try to bring some order to it
and get back to basics.
For cloud naming,
in my head,
I picture a two-by-three grid,
and maybe also a separate
box for special clouds
that don't fit into the grid.
But the two-by-three grid is a good starting point.
And fundamentally
there are two main types
of cloud.
One is a cumulus cloud,
a cumulus,
a clumping cloud,
a build-up — a gathering of moisture.
Those are heap-clouds —
they're called heap-clouds,
all the ones
with 'cumulus' in the name,
and then there's stratus,
which is a layer cloud.
Anything like, for example,
fog — that's a real layer cloud.
Anything that lies nicely horizontally
in cloud fields.
These two cloud types,
they differ above all,
they form above all,
when very strong vertical air-mass exchange takes place.
It's a layer cloud,
where everything just sits.
Just something for understanding
what happens there,
with the two cloud types.
Then onto the storey,
the different altitudes of the clouds,
we have cirrus clouds,
cirrus stands for ice crystal.
That's a very high-altitude layer,
clouds made of ice crystals.
Then we have the alto
storey.
That's the high cloud layers,
and then we have
the altitudes are always relative,
we've said this a few times.
We're talking about 3 km to 8 km.
That's not a fixed altitude.
But what's important is,
that these are the cloud names,
then we have the altocumulus
and the altostratus,
lower the cumulus and stratus.
Those are just the basic forms.
What's also important —
cumulus and altocumulus
differ mainly in that
cumulus is driven by the sun.
It's really a thermal updraft,
as we just discussed.
And altocumulus,
they don't need any sun trigger,
that happens.
There we simply have,
when a cold mass pushes into the air,
it gets lifted and forms cumulus-like clouds.
Everything on the left side
is with an unstable air layering.
The air rises well,
we're back to unstable-stable.
And everything on the right side,
if you have a stable air layer pushing into the air,
then it doesn't rise much.
And if you hit an inversion too,
you hit it,
then those are the two cloud types
that come together
from both behaviours.
It's very easy to recognise,
from the Latin names
in the grid.
Now we'll take
a few special clouds —
we have a few special boxes too.
The first cloud,
in the stratus range,
is the so-called nimbostratus,
nimbo-strat for rain.
Accordingly, a layer cloud
that really rains itself out —
we often have it with a warm front for example,
or in a low-pressure system,
in a situation where it's just pouring,
where it's just raining,
with that grey soup
hanging over you,
and the rain pouring out of it.
That's typically a nimbostratus,
so,
tucked in there.
(unclear)
What flashes and thunders and rains, and is really dangerous for us, is in this sense the cumulonimbus.
The ones that really go from the lower storey all the way up to the tropopause.
We'll come back to those in a moment.
Logically there are many more special clouds and detailed names,
but for you now, for normal flying,
the rest is really what's relevant.
If you want to dig further, look it up.
On the topic of clouds, there's also cloud cover,
which you'll read again and again in weather reports or for gliding,
weather reports, etc.
It's always expressed in eighths.
So eight-eighths cover is a closed cloud cover.
You can't see any blue sky, it's completely covered.
Zero eighths means logically no clouds — maybe just blue thermals,
perhaps with a few wisps.
We always come back to nuances.
Accordingly you get different sub-grades — two-eighths means two-eighths of the sky is covered,
and the other six-eighths are blue and clear.
And four-eighths is half-covered.
Four-eighths is a pretty nice cloud cover for thermal flying.
Something between three and four eighths, when you've got nice cumulus clouds.
And there's still enough blue sky for the sun to heat the ground, for nice weather, for thermals to develop.
That's it for cloud cover.
Then a really exciting cloud is the lenticularis,
fairly special, one most pilots know or come across quickly.
Lenticularis needs two or three ingredients: it needs a mountain range.
The other is very strong wind — so lenticularis clouds
always indicate very, very strong winds aloft.
And of course we need a bit of humidity for them to form.
It usually happens directly above mountain summits, or on the lee side of a range.
Because rotors form there — the air moves in a wave,
what we call a standing wave, because it always moves up the wave,
the air rises, forms a wave shape,
then sinks again, stops condensing, and you get wave clouds.
What's important for us to know for flying
is that this means very strong winds.
But because the mountain stays in the same place,
it stays.
And the wave, the standing wave, more or less always stays in the same place,
the cloud stays stationary.
So the air parcel rises, sinks again and stops condensing.
And accordingly we get clouds that look
as if humidity is supplied to them.
But the cloud always stays in the same place.
That's an important thing.
So just because a cloud stays still doesn't mean there's no wind.
Of course.
But the cloud shapes are very striking.
And for all paraglider pilots, it's always a bit of an alarm sign
when you see a lenticularis cloud.
Exactly.
The most important topic for paraglider pilots is always thunderstorms.
With thunderstorms, the thing is, a thunderstorm is really nothing other than
a cumulus cloud that has grown and grown and grown and grown.
It's really one huge mega-thermal cloud.
And that's what makes it so dangerous for us,
because when we fly thermals, we fly exactly on those days
when storms can develop or when there may be storms.
And so we really need to know clearly
what the dangers of thunderstorms are, and we need to be careful
when the thunderclouds naturally get bigger.
It usually starts in the morning,
the first cumulus clouds,
we go flying around eleven,
everything beautiful, wonderful flying conditions.
And then the thunderclouds, or the cumulus clouds, really get a bit bigger.
And of course they develop with the sun.
We always need the engine of the sun.
And the engine slowly starts up like an ignition,
let's say, like an engine that's just being started up.
And we have to slowly start being careful,
when the cumulus clouds, the cloud bases,
start joining together.
We had small clouds.
And for example, two clouds merge.
But now we're talking about large surfaces.
It's no longer little puffies,
but really large clouds
that have several kilometres' extent.
And as soon as the cloud bases,
the water droplets,
and eventually, when the cloud gets really tall,
we can block out the sun's rays.
And that's the point
when the cloud slowly starts getting dark.
The shadow, underneath, beneath the base, also gets dark.
And that's the point
when you have to start paying attention.
And of course it has a lot to do with experience —
how long do we still fly,
how long do we stay under this cloud?
Is it already a big cloud or not?
That's really in the area
where as you progress
you learn more and more,
because it really comes down to flying experience.
And one basic rule is:
when it starts lifting everywhere,
it's always hard
to find the thermal, to find the local updrafts.
And then it starts lifting everywhere,
all over the valley,
no falling air.
It rises and the cloud grows,
and that's when you really need to be careful.
Then the thunder
from the storm slowly starts.
And yes, if
they keep merging more and more,
they come together,
they get higher and higher.
And it doesn't really need any more power
from the sun,
because the storm starts of course
to spin a lot more.
Because warm air rises,
cools off,
cools further,
and then, when it's cold,
the air sinks,
the warm air
rises even faster, and you get a chain reaction,
a turbo,
that starts running.
And the cloud doesn't always grow,
but often grows up to the tropopause.
And then you get the beautiful anvil shapes of the cloud.
That's when the thundercloud
hits the top,
the tropopause —
you can imagine it
like a plexiglass lid above the cloud,
and then it can only spread sideways
and forms the anvil.
And in this phase,
when it's really developed,
there's a lot of friction
in the air masses
as they rise and fall.
And in this process
you get lightning sometimes
and above all there's precipitation.
Hmm.
More on that.
And something
I really want to drum in
is:
everyone is scared of a thunderstorm
when they're under it,
and you know the stories
that should never need to be told,
about the pilots and so on.
The updraft is also extreme,
so we really need to be careful.
Hmm.
But what we have to be even more careful of
is the danger
from the outflow of the thunderstorm.
The air mass
that rose and got extremely cooled off,
up at 13,000 metres,
cools at some point,
and it's like a bucket
that gets emptied out.
And accordingly
it empties out, the warm,
the cold air comes out,
the precipitation,
the released cold.
It hits us and
we don't want to be in it,
and these are real examples.
And it's very, very unpleasant.
This cold air, the outflow,
can in some circumstances,
when the next thunderstorm triggers,
where again warm air masses,
say in the valley floor lying there,
cold air comes down,
the warm rises further
and you get the next storm cell
and even more storms.
So we really need to be careful
of these cold outflows from thunderstorms.
It's almost as dangerous as being under them.
In any case it's dangerous,
but cold outflows are something
that unfortunately many pilots underestimate,
again and again.
Now you see,
if you see one here too,
looking like that,
if you of course don't want to be flying out
with a cloud like that,
then it's all over anyway.
It's an ultimatum
either to land,
or fly as far away as possible,
and then as fast
as possible, land.
But if it actually looks like this,
then it's no longer good for flying at all.
It's a real outflow,
you can really see,
how it's like a bucket of water being emptied,
with massive cold air being expelled.
And that means a lot of wind.
Then again with radar,
as already mentioned,
it's important
to watch the radar,
to see what's happening.
Watch the clouds in the surroundings,
whether we're under the cloud
or not, how high it is,
also look elsewhere,
maybe the other clouds 50 km away,
and if there's already a huge tower there,
then we know
that maybe the cloud above us isn't much smaller.
So with radar it's really important.
Watch the radar,
that's a good thing,
but also keep watching the clouds back there.
The zones I want to point out here,
the lookouts,
where you can fly in front of the cloud.
But of course with thunderstorms,
really be careful.
It has a lot to do with intuition,
and it's often a game with fire
when it really comes to thunderstorms.
Exactly.
Then we can move to the next important chapter,
the valley wind system.
It's a really important phenomenon,
which by the way happens in all regions,
including the Alps.
And it goes back and forth.
Now we keep tying more things together.
We have solar radiation,
where in mountainous areas much more heat is produced,
or they heat up better,
than the flatlands.
Accordingly,
you get heating around the Alps,
in this case,
a lower air pressure forms during the day.
And you can have air masses,
because pressure always equalises,
lower pressure in the flatlands,
and lower pressure in the mountains.
Accordingly you get equalising flows over the course of the day.
Profile.
Note the cross-section of changes,
with high pressure,
as it cools through isobars.
You can see,
of course it's never quite drawn like this,
in isobars in the cold air.
But at least higher pressure and lower pressure.
But exactly the same weather,
with the pressure equalising,
with the wind system,
that arises.
Accordingly you get equalising flows,
during the day.
It's usually strongest.
From around eleven it starts.
The peak is around three in the afternoon,
and depending on the season,
in spring,
as soon as the summits,
the inner Alps,
around the Alpine area,
become slowly snow-free,
then it slowly starts.
And likewise,
as autumn approaches,
in summer it also
always
gets weaker into autumn.
But the peak time
is around June,
when thermal activity is at its strongest.
So it always needs
thermal activity to trigger it,
if you have an overcast sky
or inversions,
where no thermals trigger,
then you don't get a real valley wind system.
Exactly.
Accordingly at night
you get the opposite,
with a mountain wind,
which sets in.
It usually starts in the evening,
around six,
it sets in,
suddenly,
higher pressure in the Alps,
because the mountains cool down faster
than the flatlands,
the flatlands recognise this perhaps.
If you see,
it stays warm for much longer
than in the mountains,
when the sun slowly leaves.
Accordingly we also have,
again, a pressure difference,
higher pressure in the flatlands —
lower pressure in the flatlands, sorry.
Accordingly an equalising flow,
starting around six,
in the evening, slowly,
starts setting in.
We're talking about reverse thermals.
That's when,
the wind flows down off the mountains.
Meanwhile the slightly warmer air
in the valley,
starts to rise away,
and you get this reverse thermal.
It happens where the boundaries form,
what forms there,
which is usually in the valley middle.
And meanwhile,
in special spots,
for example in Interlaken,
for example,
there's a beautiful updraft,
when it comes,
you can fly into the evening,
if you're allowed to,
there are special weather conditions in places.
But that's the mountain wind,
which by the way for landing fields
is sometimes a problem,
when it lies within the flying area,
where you have high mountains,
then sometimes it's
like a switch,
where suddenly the magic,
the mountain wind, where I
have meanwhile come along,
blowing the landing field away.
That's something
you sometimes also
have to factor in,
that the mountain wind can also set in.
Exactly.
It's really important,
for example,
to know that the valley wind
is a real problem in spring,
because it can get very, very strong.
And there's a great valley wind chart
from the SHV,
then it has to do with experience,
main valley,
a new approach,
where we have like roots of a tree
all joining together.
Watch the weather in the main valley,
where you are,
where the root is,
where the metal wind blows,
where it can really hit the Alps,
where you're told,
say a tributary for example,
the Rhone valley and so on,
those are all valleys
where very strong valley wind comes,
be careful.
And then we get 50 to 60 kilometres,
that's already a valley wind.
You're thermal flying in Valais,
when you go to Valais,
for flights,
behind you maybe
super nice thermal flying conditions,
and the valley wind,
down in the valley,
is already there at the valley floor,
at 500 metres above ground,
depending,
we can fly the upper thermals,
and when the valley terrain suddenly,
has lots of wind behind the ridges,
then we really have,
in the main valleys in spring,
we have to think carefully,
about whether we land at all,
or whether we might do a top-landing,
that's something,
something,
to watch out for,
when flying in main Alpine valleys.
There's also a special phenomenon,
like Mallejour,
or the Grimsel,
those are valley winds
that spill over,
spill out over a pass,
and then crash down on the other side,
and also very turbulent,
really nasty downflows.
Those are very local phenomena
that you need to inform yourself about,
when you fly for example
in the Grimsel area,
or in Mallejour,
you really have to be careful.
If you fly there,
find out about the valley wind systems,
what's important for the theory exam is
you should know,
the strength,
and what time they occur,
where they are,
what's there today,
the questions.
And something
that you always have to factor in.
Exactly.
Let me move
to another phenomenon,
which for flying
is already really important,
and that's the Foehn.
I always say,
there are three main hazards for paragliders.
It's thunderstorms,
it's the Foehn,
and it's probably strong valley wind,
that's the chapter.
Because with all other phenomena,
if there's strong wind at the launch,
say,
with a westerly wind,
you have very strong westerly wind at the launch,
and you notice it well,
it's not a good idea
to launch,
there's already mega wind.
And it's already been around for a while,
you've felt it coming in the air.
Foehn,
thunderstorms
and valley wind,
those are really the only weather phenomena
where on one hand the flying weather
can change extremely fast,
it can flip very quickly.
And on the other hand
they're usually strongest
at the landing field.
So it can be,
that with valley wind, at the top of the mountain you launch
and have calm conditions.
And down in the valley it's so strong,
you have really mega amounts of wind.
With Foehn
it's exactly the same phenomenon.
Maybe on Foehn,
how does it come about?
How much?
Wind system?
What's needed?
A pressure equalisation?
We need the pressure difference.
We need two ingredients for Foehn.
We need a pressure difference.
And we need a large mountain range.
Namely,
Foehn,
exists in other regions of the world too,
in the Himalayas,
in others,
in the Pyrenees,
in the Alps.
The Foehn has different names again and again,
there isn't really,
one name,
that's used the same around the world,
but Foehn has become established.
And there's the North Foehn and the South Foehn,
so it goes in both directions,
of course back and forth,
for us on the northern side of the Alps
it's of course the South Foehn
that causes problems.
In this case we have on the left side,
on the right the German flatlands,
or our pre-Alps.
When higher pressure is on the south side of the Alps
than on the north side,
accordingly,
the air masses
equalise the pressure and flow
over the mountain crest.
And with Foehn it's important
that there are situations
where the Foehn is,
really sucked in from the flatlands.
You can picture it
like a vacuum cleaner on the north side.
And the air can,
really intensify it,
and the local conditions
and meteorological conditions
can really build it up in the valleys
because with Foehn we usually have something to deal with.
Beautiful weather, blue skies,
everything's gorgeous,
it would actually be super beautiful to fly,
where we'd always go out for a great session.
But that's exactly what makes Foehn so dangerous —
that beautiful weather pattern
with calm at the launch.
What happens is the air mass rises,
in this case on the south side of the Alps,
it condenses,
as
the air mass rises further,
it condenses, forms clouds, sometimes even rains out.
And it goes over the Alpine ridge,
forming the so-called Foehn wall.
It's a bit like a wall
approaching the Alpine ridge.
It goes over.
Dries out.
It releases clouds.
And the drier wind,
in the flatlands,
in the Alpine valleys,
creates of course very, very strong turbulence
and downbursts and gusts.
And also rotors,
which can sometimes
also form lenticularis
clouds.
What's important is,
with Foehn it doesn't always have to
rain on top,
and it doesn't always have to
form lenticularis clouds.
Sometimes you don't see those
and the cloud forms don't show.
That's the classic Foehn,
as it usually arises,
when there's a stable pattern.
So pressure differential is what's especially important.
(unclear)
Anyway,
well,
the mountain ridge,
the main Alpine ridge,
and we're talking about the numbers,
the isobars kink up,
at the Alpine main ridge,
that's the so-called Foehn,
(unclear)
So if on the isobar map,
across the mountain range,
across the kink,
of course a really massive kink,
then
you usually
have something to do with Foehn —
watch out.
Some won't agree,
but the isobars
compress together,
in that case in the run-up to the cold front that the Foehn brings.
That's by the way a weather pattern
that often happens here in Switzerland,
before the cold front arrives.
But what's really important is,
it doesn't always have to be in the run-up to a cold front,
it can also be without a cold front coming.
But the classic case is
a cold front afterwards washing it out.
A Foehn knee forms,
there's a Foehn flow,
and at some turning point,
the front passes through and then it's gone.
That's a kink — whether equalising flow
could go to one side or the other.
So as a rule of thumb,
look at the dashed line,
we talk about four hectopascals.
If the curve up there bulges out,
then above four hectopascals
we talk about South Foehn,
below we talk about North Foehn,
say for example on Saturday
and on Friday night,
we'd talk about North Foehn.
And this is very unstable weather,
with these forecasts.
Flying conditions go back and forth extremely,
it usually means lots of wind,
lots of movement in the air,
and as a rule, not good flying weather.
Now it's also important for you to know,
really read the weather report carefully,
and be aware
that Foehn,
sometimes breaks at four hectopascals.
Sometimes you can still fly at eight hectopascals.
It's never something to recommend,
and it really has a lot to do with experience,
and you have to know the area really well.
And I'd really not recommend
recommending flying in Foehn conditions.
You can't say
I've still flown at eight hectopascals
in this flying area,
and there was no problem at all.
Foehn can vary a lot.
Sometimes it breaks through.
Sometimes it doesn't break through.
It has a lot to do
with how strong the Foehn really is.
Sometimes overpowering.
Sometimes surprising.
It has to do with the temperature layering in the air.
Then I'd jump to the next slide.
That was two hours to argue and philosophise.
What's important is that in Foehn
(unclear)
with a Foehn tendency situation,
really think it through carefully,
before you go fly.
Foehn is something for the very experienced.
(unclear)
whether the Foehn will keep coming.
Accordingly, valleys
that run from south to north.
A bit of the Rhine valley, lots of Foehn,
also susceptible,
as opposed to a valley
that runs east to west.
The air masses we get from the south,
yes, that we have on our northern side,
are at risk in the South Foehn.
Accordingly there are special Foehn areas
where you have to be especially careful.
Inform yourselves,
with the clubs,
on various websites,
where you find information,
on whether certain areas are prone to Foehn or not.
And really be conservative
when it comes to Foehn-prone areas.
Then we have the last slide — Foehn images.
It's a beautiful wall that forms,
the air mass that sinks here at work,
presses down,
and you can really see,
really clearly,
that at the main Alpine ridge,
a real Foehn wall forms.
When you see a cloud like this,
hovering and sinking,
it's never a good thing for flying.
It would be inadvisable for motor-paragliding,
when there's Foehn,
or it's also hidden, wind.
Important.
Even with a blue sky,
where you have no cloud to recognise.
That's important for us.
Now we've really discussed the three main hazards.
We've covered the theory,
as far as it's not important for the theory exam.
We really put our heart into
meteorology with focus on flying.
You can really get into the topic,
into meteorology yourselves,
keep studying the theory
and from a really important flying-practice perspective,
also keep engaging with the topic from the land's point of view.
How does the cloud arise,
how come there's a little wind,
how come it turned out different
than I expected?
Look at the meteo forecasts,
look at other channels for weather forecasting,
really engage with meteorological forecasting.
Engage with it on different channels,
so that during flight training you can pick this up well.
Drill it in during your training.
Ask your flying colleagues.
Exchange your know-how.
Ask the locals.
When you travel somewhere, say go fly somewhere,
to fly cross-country, etc.,
talk a lot with the locals about weather phenomena.
And you'll see,
you'll learn lots that way,
and you'll start to understand the basic principles.
Above all, when you can apply it in practice and use it.
It works more and more,
that you hit the right forecast.
That you're in the right spot,
in a flying spot
where you expect thermals,
that you've made the right decision.
That's what gives me satisfaction,
and I think with meteorology especially,
it's a really motivating topic,
going from theory
to applying it in practice, with lots of joy
and being able to fly safely.
Exactly.
I wish you really beautiful flights now.
Study well,
watch the three,
watch the videos as normal.
We're looking forward to your feedback.
We wish you really beautiful flights
and a great time.
Ciao, ciao.